chers amis voici venez une année
nouvelle
je suis heureux quelques semaines après
avoir été nommé secrétaire général de
notre mouvement de m'adresser à vous au
seuil d'une année cruciale pour l'avenir
de la france 2016 a été une année
douloureuse le terrorisme islamiste qui
a fait de notre civilisation sa cible a
frappé à nos sauvagement à nice à
saint-etienne du rouvray ou encore très
récemment à berlin
face à ces actes barbares les
républicains nos parlementaires ont
pressé le gouvernement de prendre des
mesures
malheureusement la réponse sécuritaire
n'a pas été à la hauteur de la situation
comme ce fut le cas également dans bien
d'autres domaines
ces cinq dernières années ce qui a
entraîné un décrochage économique et
social de notre pays un chômage toujours
plus massif et le naufrage de notre
système éducatif
c'est dans ce contexte inquiétant que la
france va élire son nouveau président de
la république au terme d'une primaire de
la droite et du centre
unanimement reconnu comme une totale
réussite
vous avez très majoritairement fait le
choix de françois fillon pour défendre
nos valeurs
cette campagne présidentielle sera comme
toutes les campagnes difficiles
françois fillon contre sur chacun et
chacune d'entre vous militants
quatre élus notre engagement sera
décisif pour le destin de la france
je sais pouvoir compter sur vous sur
votre détermination mais pour autant
dieu n'oublie pas ce qui reste
l'essentiel et je veux vous dire mes
meilleurs voeux de santé les meilleurs
voeux de bonheur dans votre vie
familiale et professionnelle pour la
nouvelle année que 2010 est soit une
année d'espérance pour la france bonne
année à tous et à toutes
bonne année à la france